et agissent et participer à tous les
contenus du site est toujours la chaîne
public sénat en direct 24 heures sur 24
comme l'ensemble de vos émissions en vod
en accès gratuit et ligne bonjour à tous
merci de nous rejoindre en direct du
sénat pour les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement une actualité dominée
aujourd'hui bien sûr par la situation en
egypte des questions on reporte sur
cette actualité et à internationale cet
après midi à sanaa et vous le voyez sur
ces images le président du sénat gérard
larcher se dirige vers l'hémicycle
on va donc comme je le disais commencé
par une question sur la situation
internationale c'est une question posée
par le sénateur communiste robert hue
normalement c'est la ministre des
affaires étrangères michèle alliot marie
qui va lui répond le gouvernement qui
sera interpellé à une deuxième reprise
sur cette situation internationale la
tunisie l'egypte
cette fois ce sera une question de la
sénatrice socialiste monique cerisier
ben guiga et là encore c'est la ministre
des affaires étrangères michèle alliot
marie qui devrait lui répondant plus
parmi les autres thèmes abordés cet
après midi ici au sénat des questions
assez diverses qui porte sur le grand
paris sur le conseil national du
numérique sur la formation des
enseignements des enseignants pardon ou
encore sur la politique du logement et
je voulais ce kit rejoindre l'hémicycle
du sénat on va sur ces questions en
direct
on se retrouve un après ici avec les
sénateurs lee ministre pour détailler
tous ces différents points d'actualité
dans le tarn ministres d'état mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues nombreux du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité
au gouvernement j'ai rappelé que
l'auteur de la question de même que là
où le ministre pour sa réponse disposent
chacun de deux minutes trente
la parole est d'abord à notre collègue
robert hue pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen un sénateur du parti
de gauche avaient la parole je suis dans
le seul premier ministre mais chaque
collège ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le premier ministre la promesse du
président moubarak de ne pas être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
septembre n'a pas suffi à calmer la
colère du peuple égyptien
la réaction violente des éléments
troubles partisans du régime qui a fait
de nombreuses victimes dont des
journalistes en terrorisant les
manifestants ne peut que nous inquiéter
sur la suite du processus en cours
le régime à l'agonie tente-t-il de
provoquer le chaos pour conserver le
pouvoir
après la tunisie avec l'egypte
maintenant ce sont les peuples de cette
région qui ne veulent plus subir ces
régimes dictatoriaux qui nie et les
droits fondamentaux la démocratie et
oppriment les populations pour préserver
l'ordre économique libérale et protéger
des oligarchies souvent corrompus votre
politique envers ces pays à était
cynique à l'égard des peuples et
complaisante pour les pouvoirs l'absence
des pros de projets et de résultats
tangibles de l'union pour la
méditerranée que le plaisir de la
république copréside coprésidait avec
monsieur moubarak démontre l'impasse
dans laquelle vous trouvez les erreurs
diplomatiques et les fautes morales et
politiques de madame la ministre des
affaires étrangères n'ont pu que
contribuer à dégrader encore la
crédibilité de notre pays
lorsque l'image lorsque l'image de la
france de sa république sont ainsi
ternie
il revient à chacune et à chacun en
toute conscience de prendre ses
responsabilités à titre personnel pour
le ministre au titre de l'intérêt
supérieur du pays pour le président de
la république et pour vous monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre vous êtes vous est déclarée
préoccupée par la dégradation de la
situation et prononcé pour une
transition rapide vers le
gouvernement à représentation élargie il
s'agit donc maintenant de prendre des
initiatives concrètes pour restaurer le
crédit de la france
porté à nouveau nos valeurs et aider le
peuple égyptien dans sa marche vers la
démocratie la justice sociale et le
développement
quelles initiatives prendre et vous
demanderez-vous une réunion en urgence
du conseil de sécurité
quelle proposition ferait vous lors du
prochain conseil européen pour que
soient redéfinis la politique européenne
dead au développement des pays de cette
région dans un sens favorable à leur
peuple et non aux seuls intérêts du
libéralisme économique il faut une
politique qui soit à la hauteur des
mutations historiques en cours à la
hauteur de l'autorité de notre pays dans
le monde de l'honneur de la france
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
michèle alliot marie ministre d'état
ministre des affaires étrangères où il
avait la parole madame lise d'état
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur la
devise de ma famille monsieur hu c'est
bien faire et laisser dire
j'ai laissé dire beaucoup et j'ai
démontré au fur et à mesure que toutes
les attaques dont j'ai été l'objet
étaient sans fondement quelle était
ignominieuse est d'ailleurs la preuve
c'est que vous avez essayé de rebondir
de l'une contre l'autre
alors heureux monsieur hu j'ai
effectivement et le gouvernement a
effectivement autre chose à faire que de
parler de problèmes qui sont totalement
vins qui sont médiocres et qui pour tout
dire sont indignes de la politique et de
votre parti politique
alors monsieur oui la situation en
egypte est de plus en plus préoccupante
et nous le disons et je le redis ce
matin très fermement les violences d'où
qu'elles viennent doivent cesser les
egyptiens doivent pouvoir manifester
leurs aspirations
sans risquer leur sécurité sans risquer
leur vie
c'est d'ailleurs ce que la première
j'avais dit au moment de la tunisie et
ou avec le premier ministre
j'avais dénoncé mois avant que monsieur
ben avi ne part pas usage
disproportionné de la force et les morts
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle vous
êtes les uns et les autres bien mal
placé car j'ai entendu beaucoup de
choses mais après le départ du président
ben ali alors oui monsieur hu
la france a bien l'intention de
continuer à appliquer les principes de
sa politique internationale qui sont
fondés sur les pas de droit qui sont
fondés sur l'appel à la démocratie et
les libertés qui sont aussi fondées sur
le respect des peuples et de leur
souveraineté et non pas sur l'ingérence
dans les affaires intérieures
il n'y a aucune complaisance lorsque ces
principes sont mis en cause ni les
principes de démocratie ni les principes
de liberté
peut-être monsieur auriez vous pu faire
la même chose quand il s'agissait de
mouvements qui se déroulait en europe de
l'est
on vous a peu entendu aller merci
merci madame le militant la parole est à
notre collègue laurent béteille pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
n'avait la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues mais monsieur le premier
ministre ma question s'adresse à
monsieur maurice leroy ministre de la
ville du grand paris le 26 janvier
dernier
l'état et la région ile-de-france sont
parvenus à un accord au moins partiel en
vue de la réalisation des
infrastructures de transports du grand
paris
je tenais à saluer cette excellente
nouvelle qui doit beaucoup à votre
implication personnelle je voudrais
cependant ici faire une remarque et vous
poser une question je voudrais rappeler
tout d'abord que conformément à
l'article 2 de la loi
il convient de procéder par priorité au
renforcement des réseaux existants en
termes de sécurité de fréquences et de
ponctualité
c'est le sens de l'amendement christian
cambon nous avions défendu ensemble ici
même je me réjouis donc que la
modernisation des réseaux actuels en
particulier des rer était prise en
compte même si je m'interroge sur le
montant réservé à cette première
opération
j'en viens à la question qui porte sur
la desserte du plateau de saclay je
partage bien sûr avec beaucoup d'élus de
cette région la nécessité de préserver
l'existence de la zone agricole que les
projets de kloster universitaire ne
doivent pas remettre en cause
j'avais d'ailleurs déposé un amendement
à l'article 28 du projet de loi pour
préciser que cette zone de protection
devaient comporter au moins 2300
hectares de terres consacrées à
l'agriculture
ceci est naturellement pleinement
compatible avec le développement du pôle
scientifique et technologique du plateau
de saclay qui ambitionne rayonnement
international voulue par le président
sarkozy et qui est une chance pour notre
pays
c'est pourquoi il est impératif que le
plateau de saclay et les réseaux de
transports conformes à cette stratégie
ce qui suppose de pouvoir relier le
plateau à paris en moins de 30 minutes
et à roissy en moins de 50
je souhaite donc vous faire part de
l'inquiétude des élus de l'ensemble de
la communauté scientifique concernée et
des milieux économiques sur l'absence
d'accord sur la desserte du plateau
les déclarations cacophoniques les
membres de la majorité régionale ne sont
pas là pour de rassurer aussi pouvez
vous nous dire monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les mesures que vous
entendez prendre pour que ce territoire
stratégique soit convenablement
desservies et que cette desserte soit en
adéquation avec les projets de
développement du cluster et plus
simplement avec la loi elle-même
je vous remercie bon mon répondent la
parole et à monsieur maurice leroy
ministre de la ville
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur laurent
béteille nous ne pouvons que nous
réjouir avec vous de cet accord
historique avec le président de la
région ile de france jean paul huchon en
faveur des transports
vous l'avez dit vous avez raison cette
vision partagée en matière de transport
a été porté à la connaissance des deux
débats publics
elle va permettre de conjuguer les
efforts de tous pour moderniser le
réseau existant et réaliser au plus vite
un projet de métro automatique en rocade
d'ailleurs les franciliens très
largement l'ont exprimé tout au long des
deux débats publics l'urgence et je vous
rejoins monsieur bétail l'urgence sur le
réseau actuel c'est bien le rer
je vous confirme donc l'engagement
commun de l'état avec nathalie kosciusko
morizet notamment de plus d'un milliard
d'euros notamment en faveur des rer c et
d
auxquels se rajoutent le financement du
renouvellement du matériel roulant de la
ligne à sur le développement et la
desserte du plateau de saclay nous ne
sommes effectivement pas parvenus à une
vision commune je le regrette je le
déplore mais cela ne compromet en rien
les engagements de l'état le protocole
expose clairement la vision de l'état
concernant saclay et ça dessert nous
allons bien assurer une desserte de
massy saclay saint quentin en yvelines
v
sai par un métro automatique en
respectant vous l'avez dit vous l'avait
défendu dans la loi avec votre collègue
cambon en respectant la zone de
protection naturelle agricole et
forestière le pôle scientifique de
saclay sera bien alors relié à paris en
30 minutes est à l'arrêt l'aéroport de
roissy en 50 minutes
c'est un engagement ferme du président
de la république du premier ministre du
gouvernement
cet engagement sera tenu le
développement du plateau de saclay est
une condition essentielle du
renforcement de l'attractivité de notre
région capitale
vous pouvez donc compter sur ma
détermination sans faille pour le mener
à bien
en partenariat avec les acteurs locaux
car je note et ça je pense que sur tous
les bancs ici on ne pourra qu'être
favorable ici on est devant le le
conseil qui représente les collectivités
territoriales et effectivement je note
que le conseil général des
hauts-de-seine des hauts-de-seine
parlant de l'essonne à l'unanimité le
conseil général de l'essonne à
l'unanimité est tout à fait favorable à
la desserte de saclay d'envoyer conseil
général de l'essonne unanime et l'état
nous devons pouvoir y parvenir le
ministre
la parole est maintenant président yvon
collin pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
la parole monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre messieurs et mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur de l'outre-mer
et des collectivités territoriales
monsieur le ministre il ya quelques
jours le 30 janvier est enfin paru au
journal officiel le décret relatif à la
composition et au fonctionnement des
commissions départementales de la coupe
de la coopération intercommunale sdci
ces commissions bien connue des maires
et des élus locaux de nos départements
on rend très prochainement la
responsabilité de dessiner la nouvelle
carte de l'intercommunalité est ainsi
d'élaborer avec le préfet et avant la
fin de cette année le schéma
départemental de coopération
intercommunale
jeu est donc de taille puisqu'il ne
s'agit pas moins que d'achever la carte
de l'intercommunalité et ce avant le 1er
juillet 2013
or monsieur le ministre si l'on peut
accepter ces délais prévus par la loi
portant réforme des collectivités
territoriales il en va tout autrement du
calendrier précipité imposé par le
récent décret du 30 janvier
ce texte demande aux préfets d'organiser
avant le 17 mars prochain des élections
chargée de renouveler les cdc y
conformément à leurs nouvelles
compositions
monsieur le ministre ce calendrier pose
problème d'une part il est très court
trop court puisqu'il laisse à peine plus
d'un mois pour organiser mener la
campagne pour la composition des cdci et
d'autre part cette campagne va se
télescoper avec celle des élections
cantonales qui aboutira nécessairement
en renouvellement substantielle des
conseillers généraux et parfois même des
majorités départementales le jeu est
donc faussé comment tolérer que les
préfets en temps des consultations et
commence à élaborer des projets de
schéma départemental en concertation
avec tous les élus locaux qui donnent
même temps et pour le grande partie
d'entre eux se présentent devant le
suffrage universel cette situation n'est
pas acceptable dans ces conditions
monsieur le ministre pourquoi ne pas
envisager un report du calendrier du
renouvellement de ces dci
pourquoi autant d'empressement alors que
le parlement attend toujours qu'on
proposait un nouveau tableau pour la
répartition des conseillers territoriaux
comme vous oblige la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 9 décembre dernier
quand vous présenterai vous ce tableau
une chose est sûre pas avant les
élections cantonales alors monsieur le
ministre pourquoi faire preuve d'aussi
peu de considération à l'égard des élus
locaux de nos territoires
ces élus de la république qui font vivre
quotidiennement la démocratie locale je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le président pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur
philippe richert ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales donner la
parole monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président yvon
collin à votre tour de poser une
question après nathalie goulet la fois
précédente sur la question de
l'organisation des conseils
départementaux des intercommunalités
dans nos départements
je voudrais vous rappeler monsieur le
président que
c'est dans un très large consensus que
cette réforme
pour ce qui concerne l'intercommunalité
a été voté avec une petite nuance et que
le gouvernement aurait souhaité avoir
des délais un peu plus ample pour la
mise en oeuvre
c'est le parlement qui a souhaité
restreindre ces délais quelles sont ces
délais les élections permettant le
renouvellement des cdc ils doivent être
organisées au plus tard trois mois après
la publication de la loi soit d'ici le
16 mars 2011 c'est la loi c'est la loi
et c'est le sénat qui l'a voté
permettez-moi de le dire
les préfets doivent s'arrêter en projet
de schéma départemental de coopération
intégrale au plus tard le 31 décembre
les communes devront appartenir à un
établissement public de coopération
intercommunale à fiscalité propre au
plus tard le 1er juin 2013
il revient donc au gouvernement
d'organiser l'ensemble de ses procédures
en tenant compte des exigences qui sont
formulées dans la loi et vous ne pouvez
pas monsieur le président en ligne
aurait donc à partir de là qu'est ce que
nous avons fait eh bien nous avons
effectivement publié le décret le 28
janvier
vous l'avez rappelé nous avons précisé
comme le dit la loi les différentes
participations 40% commune 40% un pci 5%
syndicats 10% département 5% région mais
je voudrais rassurer les élus sur le
calendrier de cette mise en oeuvre et
vous en particulier monsieur le
président la cdc sera complétée après le
27 mars par les représentants du conseil
général puisqu'il est prévu trois
semaines après le 27 mars et nous
arrivons à ce moment là le 17 avril pour
la désignation des conseillers généraux
donc nous tenons bien compte de la
réalité qui celle de l'élection des
conseillers généraux et bien sûr la
désignation des conseillers généraux au
sein de ses sept essais c'est à cette
occasion et pas avant que ça présenté le
projet de schéma départemental de
coopération intercommunale il s'ensuivra
une phase de consultation des communes
et opci de trois mois à l'issue de
laquelle la cdc you à quatre mains pour
se prononcer trois mois plus 4 mois ça
fait sept mois
quand vous prenez les sept mois +7 3
mois au début j'ai déjà dit moi c'est la
raison pour laquelle il n'était pas
possible
aller au delà des délais simplement pour
respecter ce que la loi a proposé
récemment pour terminer vous aurez bien
compris qu après cela les élus auront
donc tout le temps nécessaire à compter
du mois d'avril pour un million de la
carte intercommunale trois sets 3 et 4
mois de leur département voilà monsieur
le sénateur monsieur le président les
éléments de réponse que je souhaitais
apporter pour vous dire que bien entendu
le gouvernement a été réactif pour
permettre à ce que nous puissions
proposer ces délais à ce que les préfets
puissent organiser et transmettre les
informations à ce que sur le terrain à
la fois des représentants des communes
mais aussi des départements et des
régions une vie c'est être les plus
opérationnels merci merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à notre collègue madame
catherine morin desailly pour le groupe
de l'union centriste avait la parole
chers collègues mais si le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues la question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre chargé de
l'industrie de l'énergie de l'économie
numérique en novembre dernier je
m'inquiétais de la disparition du forum
des droits sur l'internet sans qu'aucune
structure de remplacement ne soit
annoncée en presque dix ans il avait
prouvé son utilité et son efficacité et
travaillé depuis plusieurs mois à son
évolution institutionnelle notamment et
conformément à l'une de vos propositions
faites en 2008 pour le plan numérique
2012 à la création d'un conseil national
du numérique
rassemblant le forum et d'autres
structures pourquoi le forum n'at-il pas
été maintenu quelques mois
supplémentaires le temps que soit
installé le conseil en décembre monsieur
le ministre vous annoncer la création
d'un groupe de travail préliminaire
chargé de vous faire des propositions le
futur pour ce futur conseil ans le 20
janvier on découvrait sur internet la
mise en place d'une consultation
publique
remplaçant ainsi le comité d'experts
prévu quelles sont les raisons de ce
changement
celui ci aurait t'il un impact sur le
calendrier annoncé pour avril
on peut le penser car pour être sérieuse
une consultation nécessite un peu de
temps pouvez-vous nous garantir la
transparence des résultats certains
propos que j'ai récemment entendu de la
bouche même des responsables à ce sujet
était peu rassurant nous avons noté que
vous avez confié cette mission pdg de
priceminister un acteur du numérique
sans renier ses compétences ne pensez
vous pas qu'une personnalité moins
impliqué professionnellement dans ce
secteur ni juge les parties n'auraient
permis une approche plus objective et
globale d
les matic de cet écosystème est
aujourd'hui le monde du numérique
au delà de la méthode il ya aussi une
vraie question de fond
on voit aujourd'hui les bouleversements
dans ce secteur et les nombreuses
questions d'ordre culturel économique
financier juridique et éthique qui en
découlent ainsi pouvez vous nous
indiquer quels seront le rôle les
missions et les outils du futur conseil
sera-t-il un club d'experts défendant
les intérêts d'un secteur ou alors
s'investir hâtive dans une réflexion
plus générale jusqu'à inclure des sujets
sociétaux et éthique ce qui nous semble
essentiel ou bien encore sera-t-il un
outil de régulation
quels en seraient alors l'articulation
avec les hautes autorités avec les
autorités déjà existantes
quoi qu'il en soit sa composition devra
être équilibré représentative des
acteurs concernés
bon nombre d'entre eux s'inquiètent en
effet de l'opacité du projet enfin
autorégulation régulation législation ce
sont aussi de vrais questions auxquelles
réfléchissent les parlementaires comme
en témoignent les nombreux rapports
publiés ces dernières années en
conséquence monsieur le ministre le
parlement ne doit pas être mis à l'écart
de cette réflexion
à l'heure où la nécessité d'une
gouvernance mondiale d'internet et la
dimension multi acteurs s'imposent comme
des éléments clés j'espère que vous
serez nous apporter des réponses à ses
interrogations et je vous remercie pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur
eric besson ministre en charge de
l'industrie de l'énergie et de
l'économie numérique vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame le
sénateur morin dessailly oui nous vivons
une véritable révolution numérique
une révolution de l'internet vous le
savez nous étions ensemble ce matin à un
colloque largement consacrée à la lutte
contre la fracture numérique et toutes
les initiatives que nous devons prendre
sur ce sujet
dans ce contexte parce que la révolution
numérique affecte nos modes de travail
et nos notre façon de nous transporter
la façon dont nous pouvons accéder à une
recherche d'emploi à des loisirs à de la
culture et cetera il y a lieu de
consulter les acteurs de l'internet
avant que les politiques publiques la
loi le règlement de puisse intervenir
c'est dans ce cadre que le président
dary public a eu récemment l'occasion
d'annoncés de confirmer la création d'un
conseil national du numérique qui sera
je réponds très précisément à votre
question
une instance de consultation de
concertation avant que les politiques
publiques ne puisse agir
j'ai effectivement comme vous l'avez
souligné confié à pierre kosciusko
morizet une mission et il me remettra
son rapport avant le 15 février
au delà de des responsabilités
professionnelles qui sont les siennes et
que je confirme c'est je crois un acteur
incontesté du monde de l'internet et qui
a été reconnue comme telle dès sa
nomination il nous fera des propositions
extrêmement simple quels sont les
besoins des acteurs quels sont les
éléments de comparaison internationale
dont nous avons besoin qu'elle doit être
exactement le fonctionnement et la
composition de ce conseil national du
numérique à partir de ce rapport que je
remettrai au président de la république
et au premier ministre
il y aura la définition par décret de ce
que doit être le conseil national du
numérique et le président de la
république a souhaité nommer lui même
les personnes qui seront membres de ce
conseil national du numérique
vous aurez bien évidemment l'occasion de
vérifier que le parlement sera très
étroitement associée à ce conseil
national du numérique
nous discuterons bien évidemment du
rapport et il y aura à minima un
représentant de l'assemblée nationale et
un représentant du sénat au sein de ce
conseil national du numérique je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
madame monique cerisier ben guiga pour
le groupe socialiste devait la parole
si monsieur le président madame le
ministre
les révolutions qui ont éclaté au sud de
la méditerranée condamne les
orientations de la diplomatie
sarkozienne que vous devez mettre en
oeuvre sur l'avenir de ces révolutions
seuls les etats-unis exercent une
influence évidente alors que la france
initiatrice de l'union pour la
méditerranée est ignorée à confondre
diplomatie et intérêts économiques a
sombré de la complaisance au copinage
à force de pratiquer le double langage
le gouvernement français s'est attiré
l'hostilité de ses peuples ses peuples
spoliés du produit de leur travail
terrifié par une effroyable répression
bayonnais soumis au culte imbécile de la
personnalité que ce soit en egypte ou en
tunisie
là où selon le président sarkozy
s'élargissait l'espace des libertés
propres propos ravageur croyez moi tout
comme l'a été la vision de la brochette
de dictateurs se pavanant autour de
notre président à l'arrêt à la tribune
d'honneur du 14 juillet 2008 les
géôliers de leurs peuples fêtait la
prise de la bastille quelle dérision les
peuples du sud de la méditerranée ont
vivement ressenti ce mépris du
gouvernement français qui les condamnait
à subir des dictatures mafieuses au
motif fallacieux de protéger les
européens de l'extrémisme religieux
à cela se sont se sont ajoutés sept fois
en huit ans des lois hostile aux
immigrés et à leurs descendants devenu
français des doigts hostile aux
étudiants étrangers
ces politiques ont contribué à creuser
le fossé entre le feu la france et le
sud de la méditerranée vous tournerez
vous enfin vers l'avenir madame le
ministre
toute une jeunesse des associations des
partis politiques des syndicats des
médias défendent dans le monde arabe et
musulman
les mêmes valeurs que celles qui animait
nos jeunes ancêtres de 1789
êtes vous prête à mener une politique
méditerranéenne qui tiennent enfin
compte des oppositions et qu'ils les
respectent
êtes vous prête à recevoir des
télégrammes politiquement incorrect de
diplomates aux relations et aux sources
d'informations multiples quand quand un
juge d'instruction
sera-t-il saisies sur les avoirs de ben
ali et de son entourage
êtes vous prête enfin à mener une
politique méditerranéenne qui sorte du
carcan technocratique de l'upm pour
enfin obtenir le triomphe de la
démocratie
la parole est à beaune à michèle alliot
marie ministre d'état mais les affaires
étrangères merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame cerisier
ben guiga oui il se passe aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'événements dans le sud de la
méditerranée et nous devons
effectivement le peuple français le
gouvernement doivent être aux côtés des
peuples tunisiens des peuples égyptiens
pour leur permettre à la fois d'exercer
sans violence leur droit de manifester
leurs aspirations et également pour
participer au redressement de ces pays à
leur installation dans la démocratie et
nous l'avons proposé dans des
propositions bilatérales à la tunisie et
nous avons également appelé en egypte
les gouvernants aller vers une
transition démocratique qui permette
notamment des élections libres
oui c'est notre conception aussi des
relations internationales je tiens à le
dire et l'upm est justement l'idée qu'il
ya une grande solidarité et qu'il y a
des intérêts communs qui doivent être
défendu ensemble c'est ça et c'est ça
aussi le respect des peuples les
principes de la politique internationale
de la france que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est cela c'est le respect de
l'état de droit
on discute avec des gouvernants c'est la
nonne ingérence et c'est l'appel à la
démocratie et aux libertés
alors oui
nous sommes dans cette démarche et nous
le sommes également d'ailleurs ou plan
européen
ce sont les idées que j'ai développé
devant le conseil des ministres affaires
étrangères européens la semaine dernière
et nous allons continuer à agir en ce
sens et c'est mon travail de tous les
jours et c'est avait aussi le processus
de paix la raison pour laquelle je
reçois tout à l'heure madame ashton
c'est la raison que pour laquelle
également je tiens ce soir un dîner de
suivi de la collecte des donateurs pour
la palestine
tout ceci c'est la politique et c'est ma
politique au quotidien
alors vous voulez donner un certain
nombre de grandes leçons sur ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire ou ne pas faire je
crois qu'il faut toujours être très
prudent en la matière parce que si vous
voulez ya des questions que vous pouvez
peut-être aussi posé à vos amis j'ai lu
par exemple compte rendu du conseil de
l'internationale socialiste des 15 et 16
novembre dernier à l'invitation du parti
socialiste qui avait t-il parmi vos
invités il y avait monsieur général
trabelsi et madame à cheikh chérif qui
si je me trompe sont plus que proches de
monsieur ben ali l'avez vous oubliez ce
avez vous oublié également que le parti
socialiste attendu trois jours après le
départ de monsieur ben ali pour demander
l'exclusion du parti qu'il préside et de
l'internationale socialiste
vous pourriez vous en excuser et
monsieur gbagbo qu'attendez vous encore
pour l'exclure lui aussi et son parti de
l'internationale socialiste
en le gardant parmi vous pour vous
garder quelqu'un qui refuse et ron wood
démocratique
la parole est maintenant président adria
gottéron pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres
ma question s'adresse à monsieur luc
chatel ministre de l'éducation nationale
de la jeunesse et de la vie associative
monsieur le ministre je veux vous
interroger sur la formation des
enseignants
l'année dernière aux concours
d'enseignement ce soir du second degré
se sont présentés m'a-t-on dit 21 mille
candidats c'était un peu moins que
l'année dernière
il faut faire en sorte que les concours
de l'enseignement continuent à attirer
de bons candidats et si possible les
meilleurs monsieur le ministre le
recrutement au niveau du master est
évidemment une condition de
revalorisation aux yeux de notre société
tout entière de la condition enseignante
c'était indispensable dans une société
devenue de plus en plus exigeante
vous l'avez fait je crois que c'est une
bonne chose mais il faut
monsieur le ministre que ce cette
élévation du niveau de recrutement
ça me paraît normal s'accompagne de
mesures financières qui contribuent et
participent à cette revalorisation et
c'est le premier élément de ma question
qu'en sera-t-il exactement quand est-il
monsieur le ministre il faut évidemment
que cette que ce recrutement cette
mastérisation comme on dit s'accompagne
aussi d'une formation pédagogique
la formation disciplinaire est
absolument nécessaire on l'a parfois
oubliées mais elle n'est pas suffisante
on le sait bien il ne suffit pas de
posséder parfaitement une discipline
pour savoir la transmettre à des enfants
ou à des jeunes
il faut donc une formation pédagogique
mais une formation pédagogique qui soit
une formation pratique utile monsieur le
ministre est pas une formation théorique
alors je vous interroge vous nous avez
expliqué vous nous avez indiqué que vous
envisagiez de mettre en place avec votre
collègue ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche des masters
discipline et voir des masters en
alternance qu'en sera-t-il où allons
nous pouvez-nous nous donner des
indications monsieur le ministre n'y at
il pas là une occasion aussi de
faire en sorte qu'on distingue bien les
fonctions d'enseignement car on
n'enseigne pas dans un collège comme on
enseigne en classe terminale
il ya donc des différences à mettre en
place dans la formation des enseignants
qu'envisagez-vous de faire voilà mes
questions monsieur le ministre sur une
un sujet qui je crois intérêt cela les
français et même la france est son
avenir
la parole pour répondre au président
gottéron était monsieur luc chatel
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et de la vie associative merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur adrien gouteyron
d'abord un élément de précisions par
rapport à votre question
si le nombre de candidats au concours a
été en retrait cette année par rapport à
l'année dernière
c'est en grande partie du fait qu'une
promotion d'étudiants a pu se présenter
deux fois au concours puisque l'année
2011 est l'année de transition vers le
passage au niveau master et donc la même
génération a pu présenter l'ancien et le
nouveau concours
il faut donc attendre l'année prochaine
pour voir si nous retrouvons un nombre
de candidats au concours comparable aux
années précédentes
mais vous avez raison d'insister
monsieur le sénateur sur l'importance de
la formation initiale des enseignants
est d'ailleurs les enquêtes
internationales qui sont parus récemment
notamment l' enquête pisa démontre
l'importance de cette formation dans la
performance des systèmes éducatifs et
nous avons eu raison je crois monsieur
le sénateur de d'augmenter d'une année
la formation initiale de nos enseignants
ce qu'on appelle la mastérisation comme
le font d'ailleurs la plupart des grands
pays développés
une formation qui se déroule maintenant
à l'université et qui alterne des phases
disciplinaire à des phases pédagogiques
d'enseignement pédagogique les deux
étant très important pour enseigner
alors nous avons déjà mis en place des
formations pédagogiques 2 x 108 heures
en quatrième année d'études en 5 a mené
l'étude des stages d'observation des
stages de mise en situation qui existe
aujourd'hui
nous avons également développé des
modules de formation spécifiques pour
les professeurs stagiaires l'année où
ils vont se titularisé depuis le début
de cette année scolaire j'ai indiqué que
nous étions prêts à tenir
tirer toutes les conséquences de la
phase d'adaptation de l'année de
transition et à améliorer si c'était
nécessaire la formation l'année
prochaine nous travaillons donc avec
valérie pécresse sur des mastères
polyvalent notamment pour le premier
degré on a besoin de cette polyvalence
sur des master en alternance pour qu'il
y ait un meilleur équilibre entre
formations disciplinaires et formation
pédagogique et nous allons développer
des modules spécifiques sur certains
enseignements en primaire par exemple 75
% des professeurs des écoles sont plutôt
des littéraires il faut que avant d'être
devant les élèves ils apprennent les
disciplines scientifiques pour pouvoir
transmettre aux élèves le goût des
sciences
cette mastérisation elle se traduit
aussi par une revalorisation de la
fonction enseignante c'est un sujet très
important et je réponds à votre question
nous avons augmenté tous les nouveaux
professeurs de 10% à la dernière rentrée
scolaire c'est considérable 157 euros
par mois pour un professeur certifié 259
euros par mois pour un professeur agrégé
vous voyez nous mettons en place cette
politique qui consiste à exiger
davantage en allongeant la formation
initiale en étant plus performant et en
valorisant davantage la fonction
enseignante
telle est la politique que nous menons
monsieur sénateurs mais si c'est un
ministre la parole est à notre collègue
claude bérit-debat pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le secrétaire
d'état en charge du logement pour 15
millions de français je dis bien 15
millions la fin du mois se jouent
souvent quelques dizaines d'euros près
aujourd'hui il existe une france de la
précarité
une france qui vit qui vivre et se loger
décemment étions combat quotidien
le dernier rapport de la fondation
abbé-pierre jette un éclairage glaçant
sur une réalité dramatique inacceptable
et pour tout dire indigne de notre pays
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui la situation
s'est encore aggravée et on compte en
france 3,6 millions de noms ou mal
logées dont 33 milles sans abri cent
mille sans domicile et 117 mille sans
logement personnel
pour cela il faudrait construire plus et
surtout construire mieux
là où sont les besoins le mal logement
c'est une blessure au coeur de notre
pacte républicain vous dépendez par des
satisfécits convenu et des propositions
de réformes fiscales hasardeuses comme
le projet de fiscalité foncière
différentes selon les territoires
les solutions existent pourtant ma
question est donc simple quand
allez-vous supprimer les aides fiscales
à la construction qui sans contrepartie
sociale ne bénéficie qu'aux plus riches
car allez vous consacrer l'argent public
à résoudre réellement les situations les
plus criantes et assumez vos
responsabilités dans la lutte contre les
marchands de sommeil
quand allez vous enfin imposé dans tous
les programmes de logement 30% de
logements à prix accessible on nous
répond de la parole est à monsieur
benoist apparu secrétaire d'état chargé
du logement vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais d'abord
devant vous tous salué le travail de la
fondation abbé pierre
c'est un travail sérieux c'est un
constat sérieux ce sont des propositions
sérieuses et c'est une vraie capacité à
apporter des débats et j'aimerais que
sur l'ensemble des bancs de cet
hémicycle tout le monde suive l'exemple
des débats qui sont lancés par certaines
grandes associations voudrais également
vous dire que parmi les propositions la
fondation abbé pierre
certes yens certaines dans l'air prendre
quelques exemples si vous le voulez bien
tout d'abord la fondation abbé-pierre
nous demande de lancer une grande loi
foncière avec nathalie kosciusko morizet
à la demande du président la république
et du premier ministre
nous allons lancer une réforme de
l'urbanisme en 2011 la fondation abbé
pierre d'une demande de construire plus
de logements sociaux devrait vous
rappeler qu'en 2010 ce gouvernement
cette majorité à financer cent trente
mille logements sociaux je vous rappelle
qu'à l'époque vous étiez au gouvernement
vous en financier appel
40000 la fondation abbé pierre la
fondation abbé-pierre nous demandent de
concentré de dépenser 2 % de notre
produit intérieur brut au bénéfice du
logement cette année nous aurons fait
1,96 à savoir un record depuis 1986 la
fondation abbé-pierre nous demande de
travailler sur la précarité énergétique
ce gouvernement va dépenser 1,25
milliard d'euros dont 500 millions
d'euros au titre des dépenses passe des
dépenses d'avenir pour travailler et
faire les travaux dans trois cent mille
logements au titre de cette précarité
énergétique
enfin un dernier point si vous le voulez
bien j'ai un point sur lequel nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec la fondation
abbé pierre
c'est celui de la france de
propriétaires cette majorité ce
gouvernement souhaite que les classes
moyennes que les plus modèles les plus
modestes puissent également accéder à la
propriété
c'est notre engagement de campagne
électorale c'est notre conviction
il faut que le maximum de nos
compatriotes puissent accéder à la
propriété et pas simplement les plus
riches comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
pierre hérisson pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président je président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
chantal jouanno ministre des sports
madame la ministre je crois pouvoir dire
que l'on voit naître une adhésion des
français à la candidature d'annecy pour
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
je le dis comme sénateur de la haute
savoie élus d'annecy et en s associant
mes deux collègues jean paul amoudry
jean claude carle et bien sûr vous
monsieur le président ainsi que bernard
accoyer député de la haute savoie
président de l'assemblée nationale mes
collègues députés de la haute savoir la
très grande majorité de mes collègues
sénateurs et députés
je peux également vous assurer madame
élise que toutes les collectivités
concernées font elles aussi pleinement
mobilisés
ainsi que le monde économique et sportif
elles le sont d'autant plus que cette
candidature est en train de faire
évoluer nos montagnes verra un mode de
développement durable plus respectueux
de notre environnement
c'est notre projet à tous et pour tous
le président du comité international
olympique jacques rogge a déclaré que la
candidature d'annecy garder toutes ses
chances
toutefois il ne faut pas se cacher que
les candidatures adverses bénéficie de
moyens plus que conséquent il semble que
ce soit de plus en plus les moyens et
les réseaux qui prime
lors des candidatures pour l'accueil des
grands événements sportifs
je pense en effet ne pas être le seul à
avoir été très déçu de voir
l'organisation des championnats du monde
de hand ball de 2015 échappé à la france
alors que fallait-il le démontrer nous
sommes une grande nation du football
les experts l'ont démontré dimanche
dernier désormais madame la milice des
questions se posent
cela va faire un mois qu'une équipe
dirigeante à m'étais mise à la tête de
la candidature d'annecy
l'arrivée de charles beigbeder devrait
répondre à deux faiblesses de la
candidature
nos difficultés à nous vendre à
l'international si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi
et on y revient la nécessité de trouver
de nouveaux financements privés pour
ainsi 2018
où en est on aujourd'hui nous savons que
dans quelques jours madame la ministre
vous allez devoir défendre cette
candidature devant le comité
d'évaluation du comité olympique
international and si vous savez bien
entendu que vous pourrez compter sur les
élus de rhône-alpes de la haute-savoie
d'annecy comme le gouvernement
compte-t-il comment le gouvernement
compte-t-il s'investir pour défendre au
mieux cette candidature qui est aussi la
candidature de la france
si on va faire collègues pour vous
répondre la parole et à madame chantal
jouanno ministre des sports vous avez la
parole madame la ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur pierre
hérisson les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques sont toujours un grand
moment pour une nation c'est le moment
qui permet en général de relancer une
dynamique sportive dans un pays
nous sommes dans la dernière ligne
droite puisque la décision doit se
prendre à d'urban le 6 juillet prochain
et si j'ai souhaité que l'état
s'investisse beaucoup plus fortement
dans ce dossier c'est parce qu'il y va
de la dignité nationale
il y va de présenter une candidature
propre jusqu'au bout et professionnels
et nous avons relancé une certaine
dynamique avec une nouvelle équipe
autour d'un chef d'entreprise de sportif
et jean pierre vidal est une grande
sportive suédoise pernilla wyberg qui a
décidé de soutenir la candidature
française
nous avons relancé une dynamique avec
nouvelle stratégie à l'international qui
est pilotée par guy drut qui est membre
du comité international olympique
alors avons nous une chance de gagner
nous avons une valeur ajoutée dans notre
dossier qui est que ce sont les seuls
dossiers qui présentent des jeux dans
une montagne une haute montagne à valeur
écologique
nous allons essayer de montrer par ce
dossier qu'il est possible d'avoir des
jeux olympiques écologique dans une
montagne entre guillemets d'une vague du
21e siècle et lors de la commission
d'évaluation qui sera présente la
semaine prochaine il y aura sept
ministres sept membres du gouvernement
qui seront présents pour accueillir
cette commission si l'état doit
s'investir c'est une question de dignité
pour autant ne tombons pas dans la
caricature et dans la course à l'argent
il y aura des moyens supplémentaires
déjà cette nouvelle dynamique a permis
de mobiliser 1,8 million d'euros
supplémentaire de la caisse des dépôts
et consignations et de l'âme
pardon de la compagnie nationale du
rhône
mais il n'est pas question de budget
faramineux il n'est pas question de
tomber dans cette course à l'argent
la situation budgétaire ne le permet pas
de toute façon et je ne pense pas que ce
serait un autre honneur de cautionner
cette forme de dérivés de course à
l'argent dans le sport il vous remercie
madame la ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jackie pierre pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
le chef président monsieur le premier
ministre madame la ministre d'état
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues cette question s'adresse
à monsieur lui ni sur l'agriculture
l'alimentation de la pêche de la réu la
ruralité et de l'aménagement du
territoire
nous le savons la colère monte chez les
éleveurs français qu'il s'agisse des
éleveurs de porcs de bovins ou de
volaille avec la hausse des coûts de
production due à la forte augmentation
des prix des céréales donc des aliments
pour le bétail et des prix de vente qui
stagne
les producteurs de viande sont dans une
situation de plus en plus difficile et
qui offre peu de pauses perspectives
d'avenir le prix du blé sur les marchés
internationaux a augmenté de 94 % entre
juin et décembre dernier et ceux du maïs
de 63% la pérennité de nos filières
d'élevage est donc aujourd'hui
sérieusement remise en cause
la fédération nationale porcine a
exprimé le profond désarroi des éleveurs
la semaine dernière lors d'une grande
manifestation ici à paris aujourd'hui à
l'occasion de son congrès national tenu
à août en berceau du charolais c'est au
tour de la fédération nationale bovine
d'alerter les pouvoirs publics sur la
détresse des éleveurs
les éleveurs bovins porcins réclament
une augmentation du prix de la viande
depuis quatre ans ce secteur est en
crise et le prix de vente aux négociants
n'a pas augmenté alors que le prix à la
consommation a lui augmenté de 40% la
viande doit être acheté un prix
raisonnable afin que les éleveurs
puissent légitimement en vivre ne
faudrait-il pas se pencher du côté de la
marche des intermédiaires et de celle
des grandes et moyennes surfaces la
transparence de tête partout de rigueur
n'est ce pas le rôle de l'observatoire
des prix et des marges ainsi que celui
des interprofessions
alors que les professions céréalière est
laitiers reprennent chacune du poil de
la bête
les producteurs de viande subissent
toujours une crise
perminov qu'induit le bas niveau des
cours l'ensemble des filières d'élevage
a besoin de signaux rapide de la part du
gouvernement
en conséquence monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour plus de régulation est de soutien
en faveur d'une production de viande
française compétitive et durable
merci merci je suis un collègue pour
vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur françois baroin
ministre du budget des comptes publics
et porte parole du gouvernement vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs nos cieux le
sénateur je vous prie tout d'abord de
bien vouloir accepter les excuses de
bruno le maire qui est justement ce
moment à l'assemblée générale en train
de défendre la position du gouvernement
auprès des éleveurs et son degré
d'implication n'est plus à démontrer
c'est l'occasion pour moi de rappeler à
juste titre comme vous le soulignez vous
même l'ensemble des positions défendues
par les pouvoirs publics pour aider
notre filière en matière d'élevage
notamment le programme singulier
particulier exceptionnel en 2009 qui a
permis je crois de donner une bouffée
d'oxygène significative aux éleveurs la
poursuite des négociations avec nos
partenaires européens en la matière le
déblocage concernant la question du
stockage et la corée sont tenus par
prono le maire auprès de la commission
européenne
justement c'est sur cette problématique
d'être d'urgence à la filière d'élevage
mais là où vous avez raison c'est qu'il
faut qu'on trace des perspectives et ils
vous nous répondions à trois questions
importantes d'abord la question de
l'évolution du prix on suit la question
de la compétitivité et enfin la question
de la lutte contre la volatilité à
l'échelle internationale de cette
problématique à travers l'évolution des
machins des matières premières dans le
marché trop instable pour donner des
garanties dans la durée à nos éleveurs
d'investir durablement dans des filières
qui sont par ailleurs le fruit est
l'objet d'une grande passion et souvent
de nature familiale sur la problématique
des prix nous avons je crois avancer de
manière suffisamment importante pour
donner des garanties à court terme
le gouvernement poursuivra ses efforts
sur la problématique de la compétitivité
le gouvernement s'est engagé vous le
savez un plan d'ensemble à hauteur de
300 millions pour favoriser le
développement des filières et notamment
la reprise des installations et l'aide
aux jeunes agriculteurs et sur la
question de la volatilité là encore vous
le savez c'est une problématique qui
doit s'aborder à l'échelle
internationale
le président de la république le premier
ministre le gouvernement on en fait un
des points à l'ordre du jour prioritaire
dans le g20 à travers la problématique
des matières premières j'observe
d'ailleurs que sur la scène diplomatique
internationale nous a obtenu des
avancées puisque les etats unis eux
mêmes ont reconnu l'importance de ce
point en éléments de discussion
nous devons aussi discuté au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
et avec le mercosur pour que l'ensemble
des évolutions sur le plan international
de la question des matières premières ne
se fasse pas naturellement sur le dos
des éleveurs dont cette filière est
prioritaire pour l'agriculture française
donc pour les pouvoirs publics français
merci monsieur le ministre profite pour
dire qu'à ce moment même les députés du
bundestag sont réunis avec nos collègues
sénateurs et députés ici même pour
évoquer la politique agricole commune et
la position franco allemande sur cette
politique agricole commune donc la
parole est maintenant un monsieur
martial bourquin pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre du travail et de l'emploi chers
collègues il ya certains chiffres qui
sont bons a rappelé et des additions qui
pèse très lourd huit millions de
personnes dont 2 millions d'enfants
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
quatre millions de chômeurs en décembre
2010 deux fois la population de paris
sept cent mille personnes en situation
de chômage de longue durée un jeune
actif sur cinq de moins de 25 ans au
chômage
le chômage des seniors en augmentation
de 20% et une désindustrialisation
massive de nos territoires
derrière ces chiffres impressionnants
ce sont à chaque fois des réalités
sociales des drames humains dans les
familles est un combat quotidien pour la
dignité humaine de ces familles monsieur
le ministre une conclusion s'impose
ce bilan est votre bilan et il est
accablant monsieur le ministre quand
allez vous mobiliser notre pays tout
entier pour une véritable culture et
politique industrielle de haut niveau
fondée sur l'innovation des formations
de qualité des infrastructures
productives un financement adapté des
filières des dynamiques territoriales
en considérant les collectivités
territoriales non pas comme des ennemis
mais comme des alliés majeurs
quand allez vous sortir monsieur le
ministre de ce soi-disant un budget de
crise et d'austérité totalement
inefficace pour vous engager pleinement
dans la lutte pour le plein emploi la
croissance durable et acceptée de
redonner du lest au pouvoir d'achat
enfin quand allez vous accepter de
rééquilibrer la fiscalité pour favoriser
enfin l'économie réelle celle qui crée
des emplois
pas celle qui recrée des bulles
financières
il faut inverser le logiciel avait été
d'agir pour la force des rentiers mais
pour celles qui travaillent
celle qui se lève tôt le matin celle qui
produit des richesses et celle qui
peinent en ce moment qui n'a jamais
autant peiné moins de satisfactions
moins d'effets d'annoncé plus d'actions
vigoureuses et déterminé pour faire de
l'emploi une véritable cause nationale
bien pour répondre la parole et à
monsieur xavier bertrand ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de la santé vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur inverser le logiciel inversée
logiciel monsieur le sénateur et
comprenait bien qu au lieu d krainer les
chiffres pour essayer de faire
spectaculaire faut bien faire la
différence entre ceux qui sont en
définitive des commentateurs des
chiffres et ceux qui sont des acteurs
qui essaye de faire reculer le chômage
voilà la réalité nous savons dans quel
camp vous vous situez et nous savons
très clairement dans quel camp nous nous
situons c'est vrai que les choses sont
difficiles
les choses sont difficiles parce que
pendant la crise le chômage augmentait
dans notre pays de 33% vous le savez
bien
comme vous savez aussi pertinemment mais
là vous n'avez pas cité ce chiffre
que dans toute l'europe le chômage
augmenter de 43% et que dans certains
pays géré par vos amis socialistes le
chômage augmenter beaucoup plus c'était
le cas en espagne c'était le cas en
angleterre
alors si les choses étaient faciles ça
se saurait on n'est pas obligé de les
prendre de façon aussi manichéenne que
vous venez de le faire à l'instant
monsieur le sénateur un version
logicielle comme vous l'avait proposé en
considérant que ce sujet est un enjeu
national aujourd'hui qu'en 2010 c'est
vrai que chacun aurait aimé que le
chômage recule
il a beaucoup moins augmenté qu'en 2009
18,9 pour cent d'augmentation en 2009 3%
en 2010 et ce que nous voulons faire
avec les moyens qui sont engagés c'est
tout simplement de permettre de faire
reculer le chômage des jeunes mais aussi
d'éviter que de nombreux chômeurs ne
bascule dans l'exclusion
nous faisons une priorité c'est la
volonté du prix de la république et du
premier ministre de pouvoir faire
reculer le chômage de longue durée
sur tous ces sujets il ya deux attitudes
possibles soit de considérer que c'est
un camp contre un autre
ou alors de considérer vous parlez des
collectivités locales et bien jouer une
proposition les contrats d'objectifs et
de moyens pour l'apprentissage
si l'état met un euro que les régions
gérées par vos amis mettent également un
euro en face voilà ce qui nous permettra
aussi d'être beaucoup plus efficace
voilà ce qui nous permettra de faire
reculer le chômage des jeunes parce que
nous croyons à l'alternance
sur tous ces sujets je tiens vous à vous
le dire ça ne sert à rien de chercher à
polémiquer
les élections présidentielles sont
encore loin elles sont encore beaucoup
plus loin dans l'esprit de concitoyens
en tout cas vous vous déciderez de votre
attitude nous avons décidé de faire
reculer chômage dès cette année 2011
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous en avons fini avec les
questions d'actualité merci monsieur le
prennent au ministre merci madame le miz
d'état mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
sera repris à 16h15 pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi 2 voilà pour
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement direct de l'hémicycle du
seyon du sénat par on se retrouve tout
de suite avec noah min et des sénateurs
des ministres pour revenir sur ces
différents points de l'actualité on
refait la séance tout de suite
voilà on refait la séance et on commence
ensuite avec le sénateur ump car ils
sont bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous vous mobilisez évidemment pour pau
26 pour cette candidature aux jeux
olympiques d'hiver déjà est-ce que vous
avez été rassurés de la réponse tout à
l'heure de la ministre des sports j'ai
surtout voulu démontrer qu'il y a un
enthousiasme dans le monde économique
dans le monde sportif et parmi
l'ensemble des élus et j'allais dire de
l'ensemble de la population de notre
département une volonté après grenoble
après albertville et en 2018 annecy de
renouer avec les jeux olympiques et les
jeux paralympiques en rappelant que les
premiers ont lieu en 1924 à chamonix
donc la haute montagne et la tradition
de l'olympisme sportifs d'hiver ils ont
eu du mal quand même tous un peu à se
mobiliser autour de cette candidature ça
a été un peu poussif non non il ya eu
des mobilisations et comme toujours il y
à un certain moment des couacs pour des
raisons de personnes aux autres
aujourd'hui les choses sont bien en
marche
vous avez pu vous rendre compte que
leurs mamans et des mains sûres fiables
et la tête de cette qualité mirabeau et
bien entendu tout le corps administratif
des services décentralisés de l'état
dans le département préfet en tête le
maire d'annecy le président du conseil
général le président du conseil régional
qui est pourtant pas de la même
sensibilité politique
tout ce monde là est derrière la
candidature pour pas dire devant
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy françois
fillon vous les sentez prêt à s'engager
pour un psy complètement d'ailleurs la
semaine prochaine par moins de sept
ministres alors nous aurons la liste
très bientôt par moins de sept ministres
vont se rendre à annecy successivement
pour converser avec les membres du
comité d'évaluation et je crois que
c'est là que les choses vont se nouer
il n'empêche que il faudra continuer à
aller vers la candidature et rencontrer
et 114 votants qui vont choisir entre la
cour et l'allemagne et la france parce
que c'est bien la candidature de la
france dont il s'agit est juste un petit
mot pour finir sur le calendrier
on va connaître la décision quand sur le
calendrier et sur le calendrier
nous sommes donc début février il nous
reste cinq mois
mais quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé
avec l'angleterre avec le brésil et avec
la russie pour les dernières
candidatures
on s'aperçoit que c'est dans les trois
derniers mois que les choses se jouent à
partir du moment où chacun des membres
votants a pu faire une analyse objective
et voir l'intérêt de notre dossier qui
est développement durable et qui est
surtout la haute montagne qui par
définition la neige la glace je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui est
important pour des jeux olympiques
d'hiver et des jeux paralympiques qu'il
ne faut jamais oublier keirrisson vous
vous faites parti de la majorité
présidentielle j'ai envie de vous poser
une question assez simple pour ou contre
jean françois copé sur la question de la
tva et des charges sociales les olim de
talence élémentaires sur ce sujet et que
ce ne soit pas seulement une relation
entre des personnes et les médias mais
car ils sont beaucoup dans la majorité
dans l'ump accuse jean françois copé de
vouloir plomber
la campagne pour les cantonales non non
non je ne crois pas à ça on n'est pas
tout à fait dans le même débat que
lorsqu'il s'agit d'élire nos élus
nationaux
je crois que le débat national ne doit
pas gêner mais ne doit pas non plus
s'arrêter au motif qu'il ya des
élections locales
très bien merci beaucoup pierre et son
d'avoir été avec nous david assouline
maintenant nous allons rejoindre bonjour
david assouline peut-être déjà un mode
et des deux questions posées à michèle
alliot marie sur la situation
internationale bien sûr sur la situation
en egypte mais également sur son fameux
voyage fin décembre en tunisie est ce
que vous êtes de ceux qui au sein du
parti socialiste demande la démission de
la ministre des affaires étrangères
là je veux pondérer ce qui a été dit
parce que personne n'a évoqué
directement les problèmes personnels de
madame alliot marie les choses ont été
posées politiquement dans les deux
questions par le parti communiste puis
lycée parti socialiste
mais la réponse de la ministre a été
d'une extrême violence et je pense qu'il
faut reprendre ses esprits parce que
dans cette affaire c'est la diplomatie
française et l'image de la france qui
est en jeu
donc moi je n'ai jamais été de ceux qui
personnellement à chaque fois qu'un
ministre ait un écart demandé la
démission parce que le président est
responsable premier ministre est
responsable et mini savent ce qu'il doit
faire mais ce n'est pas attendez ce
n'est pas nous qui avons composé de
gouvernants mais là on est dans un
moment particulier où je pense que ces
erreurs les fautes qu'elle a commis ce
cas là quasi admise au moins dans
l'expression les derniers événements
révélée par le canard enchaîné qui au
moins monde qui a déjà désinvolture
qu'une ministre à un moment où déjà il
ya une émulation par le feu de ce jeune
tunisien puisse être si si inconsciente
au mieux dans son voyage personnel en
tunisie ministre des affaires étrangères
de la france ne pas reporter eu un tel
voyage privé alors que la situation est
chaude je pense que c'est l'imprudence
mais maintenant il s'agit de l'image de
la france et donc deux qu'elle peut
rester à son poste non jeudi comme il
s'agit de l'image de la france je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un geste fort
pour restaurer la crédibilité de la
diplomatie française à elle et au
premier ministre et au président de la
république de prendre les décisions je
ne pense pas qu'elle réussira à partir
de maintenant à avoir une crédibilité en
particulier dans cette partie du monde
pour représenter notre grand et beau
pays je suivais bien sûr avec intérêt
les événements aujourd'hui encore en
egypte vous qui suivez notamment
particulièrement ici au sénat la
question des journalistes beaucoup de
journalistes français et étrangers ont
été arrêtés sont maltraités aujourd'hui
en egypte vous êtes inquiet oui moi je
suis inquiet bien entendu parce que on
voit que ceux qui à un moment du
processus tunisien a été tentée par les
restes du clan ben ali qui était de
faire qui est des provocations des
milices un peu le ko allait s'attaquer
aux gens n'a pas marché et la remet
d'ailleurs à ce moment là a joué un rôle
assez de pacification en egypte là les
choses paraissent beaucoup plus
houleuses d'abord il apparaît que
monsieur moubarak s'accroche
monsieur ben ali lui s'était vite enfuis
il s'accroche et puis cette cette
violence qui s'est exercé cette nuit et
qui semble continuer essayant de
provoquer un chaos dans une situation
presque qui se transformerait en guerre
civile entre partisans de monsieur
moubarak et les autres est très
préoccupant et il faut là que tout notre
diplomatie la communauté internationale
la france agissent comme l'a fait les
états unis pour que la transition soit
rapide et qu'il puisse y avoir une
marche rapide vers la démocratie là bas
très bien merci beaucoup david assouline
d'avoir été avec nous on accueille
maintenant le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement patrick
ollier bonjour merci d'être avec nous le
sénat qui examine cette semaine le
projet de loi sur l'immigration
avec déjà une disposition importante 1
de ce texte
qui va être en discussion dans
l'hémicycle ça va reprendre dans
quelques minutes
je parle de la de l'extension de la
déchéance de nationalité est ce qu'à
votre avis il va y avoir au sénat c'est
d'après midi une majorité pour voter
cette disposition du projet de loi du
gouvernement pour être très franc les
impressions qui ressortent des contacts
que j'ai me laissent penser qu' il y
aura quelques difficultés pour voter
cette disposition je souhaite néanmoins
qu'elle soit votée
je le souhaite et les sénateurs vont se
prononcer à leur âme et conscience
c'est un problème consigne de vote au
sein du groupe ump
non non sur des sujets de ce genre là il
n'y a pas de consignes de vote qui sont
donnés il gouvernement ça remettra à la
sagesse des assemblées mais toute
manière le débat n'est pas achevé et il
y encore des épreuves parlementaire
avant que le texte soit définitivement
voté mais nous souhaitons quand même que
cette disposition soit à voter parce que
lorsqu'il y à des crimes odieux lorsque
cela concerne des personnes dépositaires
de l'ordre public il faut que ces
personnes-là sache qu'il y a une
réaction forte de l'état et la déchéance
de nationalité doit pouvoir en faire
partie tout cas c'est le sentiment du
gouvernement il ya un autre point de
divergence assez fort et concret au sein
de la majorité sur la rétention des
sans-papiers est-ce que là aussi ça va
être difficile de trouver une majorité
je suis
la plus optimiste sur cette mesure
lassitude mesures de bon sens ce n'est
pas un cas de conscience
le problème de la déchéance de
nationalité pète rhee dans les cas de
conscience dans les problèmes de
conscience légitime de chacune et chacun
des sénateurs
s'agissant du problème des cinq jours du
délai de rétention de cinq jours c'est
un problème de bon sens ça n'a rien à
voir la conscience il faut rétablir
l'ordre des juridictions et la
juridiction administrative doit pouvoir
s'exprimer pour que le juge du
judiciaire puisse après c'est-à-dire
délai de cinq jours s'exprimer lui aussi
et avoir le dernier mot car en
définitive c'est lui qui doit voir les
animaux donc il faut ces cinq jours
puisqu'il ya 72 heures il ya 48 heures +
72 heures ça fait cinq jours avant new
delhi six aspects notamment des jets
l'hiver des libertés puis la même
mission des lois est contre cette
disposition là justement je suis étonnée
qu'elle soit contre parce que c'est
justement pour respecter la hiérarchie
des juridictions et faire en sorte que
le judiciaire puisse s'exprimer en
dernier que nous souhaitons que ces
dispositions soient prises parce que si
d'aventuré un juge s'exprime avant
l'autre qui n'a pas le dernier mot et
que on relâche la personne en question
forcément lorsqu'elle est partie on ne
peut plus la rattraper et appelé la
justice ne peut pas avoir le dernier mot
non il faut que ce soit le judiciaire
qui est le dernier mot dans cette
affaire donc pour rétabli simplement
l'ordre des juridictions ça n'a rien
d'un dame d'inconstitutionnelle c'est du
bon sens je le répète et j'espère que le
sénat sera sensible à cet argument
vous vous d'ecrouves vous connaissez
bien l'assemblée nationale vous
découvrez tout l'art de la négociation
qu'il faut déployer ici au sénat où il
ya longtemps que je connaissais n'a vous
savez dans une autre vie j'étais
conseiller de premier ministre et de
ministre du visa justice alain
peyrefitte notamment et j'ai vécu des
heures passionnantes aussi là à l'époque
pour faire voter le texte sécurité
liberté il défend des ya très longtemps
que je connais ça j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour le travail que pour le
sénateur et moi qui pendant vingt ans
était député et président de commission
à l'assemblée nationale
je ne connais parfaitement l'assemblée
vous avez raison mais j'ai toujours là
où j'étais à l'assemblée toujours eu
beaucoup de respect pour la position des
sénateurs qui prennent un peu plus de
recul que nous peut être à l'assemblée
et apporte par ce qu'on appelle à la
sagesse du sénat
un équilibre qui est nécessaire aux
institutions dont je suis très à l'aise
au sénat ya pas de soucis au sol à la
majorité présidentielle au sein de l'ump
en ce moment patrick ollier le climat
est un peu tendue entre les pro et les
anti jean françois copé vous vous placez
dans quel camp moi je me place dans le
camp de ceux qui sont derrière nicolas
sarkozy et qui veulent le faire gagner
la prochaine élection présidentielle il
assure tous servir nicolas sarkozy est
ce qu'il faut c'est en 50p lancer des
idées des débats de près et faire vivre
je suis à tenter débat politique et
public je suis attentif à ce que vous
dites est ce que les journalistes disent
mais c'est une tempête dans un verre
d'eau
nous sommes à l'ump tout à fait unis
dans les intentions du président de la
république et l'action qu'il conduit
d'ailleurs le premier ministre si le
président de la république a souhaité
que jean françois copé dirige l'ump
c'est qu'il avait ses raisons
ces raisons je les respecte et je
soutiens jean françois copé à la tête de
l'ump avec mes amis cela étant on peut
on peut discuter de savoir s'il faut
plus débattre ou moins débattre sur tel
ou tel sujet mais c'est bizarre comment
comment les choses sont faites dès que
imparti débat je vois parler du parti
socialiste mais c'est pareil pour le
parti socialiste c'est la pagaille
et si nous disons rien alors nous sommes
des godillots si dieu me dire où il faut
mettre le curseur du débat ça me ferait
plaisir mais certains cuisse quand même
genre consacrée aux autorités de plomber
de pénaliser la campagne des élections
cantonales
je vous rassure mais je sais pas sur
l'a10 à votre antenne mais moi j'ai pas
entendu dire ça bon ainsi et des élus
ump qui sur le terrain sont à des
métiers tdc de l'ump je viens quoique
les mêmes pays qui ont des cantons
renouvelables la circonscription jeanne
et de la mienne d'ailleurs qui sont
inquiets parce que telle ou telle par le
tel ou tel sujet dias avoir des
répercussions dramatiques damas est
constamment canton c'est certainement
vrai c'est pas pour autant qu'il ya une
remise en cause la hiérarchie du
mouvement parce qu'il faut bien qu'on
débatte
si on veut que les français comprennent
ce que l'on veut faire pour l'avenir du
pays dans les deux ans qui viennent qu'à
travers la future campagne
présidentielle
il faut bien qu'on ouvre le débat dès
aujourd'hui donc je suis pas gêné par le
débat mais il faut effectivement
peut-être limiter les la dimension de
ces débats là pour éviter ce que vous
dites et c'est entre nous au bureau
politique nous avons discuté encore hier
matin et nous en avons discuté avec
beaucoup de conviction et jean françois
copé a été tout à fait d'accord nous
allons faire en sorte que les débats qui
seront soumis à l'avis du public dans la
mesure où on va débattre avec les
français parce que l'ump veut débattre
avec les français soient hiérarchisées
pour que ça rentre plus dans une
cohérence de la vision qu'on souhaite
avoir pour après 2012 pour la france et
les français
patrick ollier je peux pas vous laisser
partir sans vous demander comment vous
vivez la tempête médiatique que traverse
un michèle alliot marie cette semaine
très mal très mal parce que
je suis choqué de l'outrance des
accusations
je suis choqué des amalgames qui sont
faits et des suspicions qui sont créés
parce que si quelqu'un et suit une ligne
droite dans le cadre justement de cette
volonté de ne pas mélanger la vie privée
et la vie publique c'est bien michel si
quelqu'un respecte les critères de
l'honnêteté jusqu'au bout des ongles
c'est bien elle aussi et c'est très
injuste que ce soit elle qui soit frappé
par cette polémique qui est une
polémique de mauvaise foi
incontestablement je suis associé aussi
puisque j'étais avec elle et nous étions
avec ses parents et on passe toujours de
vacances en famille d'ailleurs tous les
ans et je trouve ça choquant alors quand
il attaque par rapport à ce qu'elle dit
ou ce qu'elle ne dit pas dans le cas de
la politique étrangère c'est légitime
mais ceci est malveillant et frapper les
gens dans le dos se sait c'est pas
correct
voilà alors vous me demandez ce que j'en
pense j'en souffre pour elle et j'en
souffre aussi personnellement parce que
c'est douloureux supportez-vous la santé
suffisamment solides pour traverser ce
moment je me caille pas pour ça elle et
elle est suffisamment solide mais elle
ressent ça comme une profonde injustice
et l1 souffre également pas s'imaginer
que michel n'a pas de coeur il faut pas
s'imaginer que tout ceci ne la touche
pas bien sûr que les toucher mais quand
même quand on est ministre des affaires
étrangères inconso rend dans un pays où
il ya des troupes qui ont commencé il
faut faire attention
excusez moi les troubles ont commencé le
jour où nous sommes arrivés
enfin même pas même pas parce que c'est
ça les troubles ont commencé dans la
faim dans les manifestations
quand nous sommes partis mais le
la sphère du jeune qui s'est immolé au
feu c'était le jour même de notre
arrivée donc très sincèrement à tabarka
nous étions dans un hôtel franchement
moi je n'avais pas la sensation qui se
passait ces problèmes là en tunisie
michèle savait bien qu'il y avait des
tensions fortes mais je crois savoir que
tous les commentateurs au monde à
commencer par en tunisie les
responsables du gouvernement ne l'ait
pas conscience que de ce qui se passait
et que le jour même du départ de
monsieur ben ali le matin personne
n'aurait misé un centime sur le fait
qu'ils partent le soir donc il faut
aussi ramener chaque chose dans son
contexte et à sa juste valeur cette
vigilance c'était oui c'est dur mais je
le prends comme ça c'est une leçon de
vigilance et très sincèrement ça va
m'amener ça va l'amener probablement à
réfléchir à deux fois
parce que nous ferons les week-end
prochain les vacances prochaines très
bien merci beaucoup
patrick ollier d'avoir répondu en direct
à nos questions bariza khiari sénatrice
socialiste et maintenant avec nous
bariza khiari vous vous connaissez bien
sûr très très bien le maghreb tout le
monde arabe
comment vous vivez depuis quatre cinq
six semaines tout ce qui se passe dans
ces pays il a écouté avec bonheur et
appréhension avec bonheur parce que dans
ces manifestations est démontré que
l'obsession islamistes et une hypothèque
qui a été mise en avant et qui est
complètement fausse ces gens ont besoin
de liberté et ils se sont retrouvés face
à des dictateurs les colons est en
partie on a mis des colons qu'on pouvait
diriger de loin donc là tout d'un coup
il ya un souffle de liberté incroyable
et cette obsession de l'islamisme et
finalement a disparu donc avec bonheur
et avec appréhension même sur les
transferts sur la situation et les il ya
des craintes mais avec appréhension par
rapport aux transitions parce que j'ai
quand même le souvenir du bonheur de
certains quand il y a eu la révolution
la révolution iranienne
et puis les déceptions qui sont arrivés
derrière donc il faut être très prudent
et
je n'en rajouterai pas là dessus en
revanche sur le projet de loi
immigration
j'aimerais dire un mot on va en parler
avec françois noël buffet sénateur ump
qui viendra le rejoindre
très bien mais c'est un très bon
rapporteur babala mais une remarque
d'une observation générale sur sur la
question du texte j'ai remarqué pour la
première fois fait que ces rares cette
année que nous ayons un texte qui soit
un texte qui ne soit pas dans une
procédure accélérée
ce n'est pas dans les procédures
d'insérer un bon point non non je dis
pas qu est un bon point
j'ai des doutes sur skier sur les
raisons et je me demande c'est une
question que je me pose comme beaucoup
d'autres si on ne veut pas commencé à
distiller les thèmes de la future
campagne électorale qui qui s'annonce et
marine le pen ayant posé les thèmes
concernant les musulmans
la droite républicaine pour gagner les
élections pourrait poser les thèmes sur
l'immigration et ça se rejoint alors que
c'est quand même activer le rapporteur
du projet de loi ici au sénat va vous
répondre tout de suite parce qu'après je
sais qu'il doit rejoindre l'hémicycle où
l'examen du texte va reprendre dans
quelques minutes
françois noël buffet jeu peut-être déjà
pour répondre à bariza khiari d'abord
pour dire qu' on ne sait plus finalement
à quel saint se vouer soit on est en
procédure accélérée et nous sommes
critiqués sont les temps procédure
jaillir parlementaire normale et nous
sommes critiqués
bon ce que je veux dire c'est que moi
j'apprécie le fait qu'on soit dans une
procédure parfaitement normal qu'ils
laissent la place au débat à la
discussion au travail avec l'ensemble
des collègues et qui va permettre à ce
texte de mûrir dans le cas de ce que
l'on appelle traditionnellement la
navette parlementaire donc tant mieux
pour une fois alors justement le débat
il va avoir lieu là cet après midi ça va
reprendre avec notamment les
dispositions autour de la déchéance de
l'extension de la déchéance de
nationalité
patrick ollier qui était à votre place
il ya quelques instants nous disent
qu'un et sans doute pas de majorité pour
voter cette disposition c'est aussi
votre avis je crains de devoir le
regretter
je crains de voir le regretter en tous
les cas nous nous verrons tout à l'heure
mais il ya un débat de fond important
moi je voudrais simplement dire que sur
ce sujet là la commission des lois a
repris le texte venant de l'assemblée
nationale l'a encadré encore plus
juridiquement pour qu'il réponde au
caractère constitutionnel de celui ci
pour que les preuves de ce que pourront
prononcer les magistrats soient
parfaitement aussi encadré et puis sur
le plan sur le fond sur le fond il est
vrai que on devrait se poser la question
suivante me semble-t-il lorsque la
france octroie la nationalité française
à un étranger qui le demandent quelle
que soit l'étranger bien évidemment il
est peut-être normal aussi qu'elle se
pose la question de cet octroi lorsque
les atteintes à l'état sont extrêmement
fortes c'est la seule question qu'on
doit se poser ensuite de régler les
problèmes juridiques de façon très
précise voilà je vais devoir vous
quitter parce que là c'est juste une
toute petite dernière question les
magistrats du tribunal de nantes se sont
mis en grève cet après midi après les
déclarations ce matin du chef de l'état
dans la sphère de la jeune laetitia qui
a été assassiné le jade de l'état
réclamé des sanctions contre les graves
dysfonctionnements qui a eu lieu dans la
police et dans la justice
vous êtes d'accord avec ce propos du
chef de l'état je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire sur ce qui vient
d'être dit si il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements il doivent être
données établies il ya des procédures
pour cela à quelqu'un eh bien on en tire
les conséquences
en revanche s'il est établi qu'il n'y en
a pas eu et bien sûr voilà que les
choses soient très simple et
transparente
il se peut qu'il y a eu d'édition
seulement je suis incapable de vous le
disais magistrat côté il se peut s'il y
en a il faut régler ce problème là dont
acte
mais je ne veux pas faire plus loin de
commentaires en l'état très bien je vous
laisse juge
la séance qui vient de démarrer un
nouveau sur le projet de loi immigration
françois noël buffet merci d'avoir été
avec nous bariza khiari juste peut-être
pour finir avant de tenter un autre
débat sur légiste sur ce projet de loi
immigration il le ministre de
l'intérieur brice hortefeux a également
déposé un amendement pour un régime
spécial de rétention pour les étrangers
terroristes est-ce que là il faut suivre
le gouvernement écoute et pour le moment
nous en sommes dans le dans le débat
tout à l'heure à la déchéance de
nationalité
alors moi j'espère j'ose espérer que les
centristes qui sont ici la minorité de
blocage et qui ont toute leur importance
iront jusqu'au bout de leur qui seront
en cohérence avec les valeurs qui sont
les leurs et qu'ils feront ce front
républicain que nous attendons depuis
longtemps invisible n'est pas être là
visiblement ils ont bien raison de le
faire
j'espère qu'ils vont tenir j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure patrick ollier françois
noël buffet ont confirmé qu'il n'y
aurait sans doute pas de majorité au
sénat
vous allez accéder c'est que ça sent la
ce week-end front républicain comme nous
l'avons fait pour l'adn ici et l'honneur
le sénat s'honorerait de de vraiment de
supprimer cette disposition qui est
anticonstitutionnelle à nos yeux très
bien mais voilà une amie le centriste
qui va peut être répondre et j'espère
qu'ils seront là ou pas là
cet après-midi des attentes de nos
attentes a effectivement catherine morin
desailly merci d'être avec nous juste un
petit point avant de parler de nos jours
pardon avant de parler de l'egypte pour
finir sur le projet de loi immigration
vous confirmer que votre groupe ne
votera pas l'extension de déchéance de
nationalité tout à fait c'est une
décision collégiale de notre groupe d
centriste catherine morin desailly vous
êtes la présidente ici au sénat du
groupe d'amitié france egypte est ce que
vous êtes inquiète
cet après midi des heurts au caire de
tous les problèmes de la tacc des pro
moubarak
comment vous sentez l'ambiance vous
savez quand il ya de la violence quand
il ya des victimes on est forcément
toujours inquiet attentifs à la façon
dont les événements se déroulent et la
façon dont ils vont
se dérouler dans les jours qui suivent
même si on sait que les mouvements qui
ont lieu à l'heure actuelle sont aussi
des aspirations à plus de liberté et
plus de démocratie dont vous avez
l'impression aujourd'hui que le pouvoir
cherche à gagner du temps je crois que
le pouvoir essaye différentes solutions
peut-être avant d'être obligés d'aller
plus loin toute cette semaine va sans
doute être très décisive à être traité
sans doute cette journée est la journée
de demain vendredi qu'elle entendait
journée traditionnelle de la prière
monique cerisier ben guiga nous a
rejoints bonjour vous connaissez
extrêmement bien cette région comment
vous vous voyez sur place le rôle de
l'armée on a vu ces instants de
fraternisation au départ et puis on a vu
que l'armée non plus ne faisait rien
contre le président moubarak
comment vous vous sentez vous voyez les
choses en effet ce qui en ce moment et
c'est de gagner du temps c'est très
certainement les généraux parce que
l'armée et le la force politique et
financière principale du pays
elle possède la plupart des terres à
construire elles possèdent du 1/4 d'un
très grand nombre d'industries et les
militaires de haut grade bénéficient
d'un niveau de vie tout à fait favorable
et en général en lien avec le monde
industriel
donc il n'est pas étonnant que l'egypte
que l'armée égyptienne qui est une armée
de conscription actuellement soit dans
une phase attentiste où on laisse les
conscrits fraterniser avec le peuple
mais où en même temps on attend un petit
peu avant de laisser tomber moubarak
moi ce qui m'étonne c'est que les états
unis ont décidé en deux jours de laisser
tomber ben ali et qu' ils attendent pour
laisser tomber au maroc et est quand
même eu un appel à une transition
démocratique beaucoup plus rapides de la
part de barack obama de la part
d'hillary clinton
oui mais le problème est de savoir à
quel moment on laisse tomber un
dictateur et se dit et quel est le
danger de le laisser tomber trop vite
or pour les états unis l'enjeu égyptien
est énorme
parce que c'est le pays qui
démographiquement pèsent le plus lourd
et c'est le pays qui en 1979 a traité 1
signé paix avec un traité de paix avec
israël
donc les états unis ne peuvent pas
prendre de risque avec l'egypte même si
ça coûte des 1000 des morts et des morts
et des blessés au peuple égyptien
comme il l'a fait pour la tunisie vous
vous l'avez rencontré le président
moubarak
l'un de vos nombreux voyages que j'ai
rencontré surtout omar souleimane et
dans le rapport que j'avais fait à
l'époque avec mon collègue jean-françois
penser nous avions dit c'est évidemment
lui qui détient les rênes du pouvoir et
c'est lui qui pourra prendre la
succession n'est sûrement pas le fils
moubarak
mais je voudrais leur dire un point je
crois qu'il faut pas parler de pro
moubarak dans la journée d'hier ce sont
des des nervis un si lourd n'est plus
très bien compris ce sont des hommes de
main des voyous tirer des prisons à qui
on donne des gourdins et qui ont pour
pour aller taper sur les manifestants
c'est un set un grand classique
en écho à l'appel de barack obama il y a
deux jours à une transition a accéléré
vers plus de démocratie en egypte il y a
eu ce communiqué ce matin de quatre
chefs d'état important au niveau
européen dont nicolas sarkozy et dont
david cameron donc les espagnols et les
excès de tera mais l'egypte refuse toute
ingérence mais l'egypte doit se réformer
et doit poursuivre ses réformes
d'ailleurs nous avions prévu
avec un groupe trans partisan de
sénateurs de nous y rendre d'ici
quelques jours bon nous allons reporter
notre déplacement pour des raisons
évidentes d'opportunités notre le but de
notre déplacement était justement de
mesurer l'état de l'amélioration de ce
qu'on appelle l'état de droit des
libertés la façon dont les réformes de
s'engager s'engager tel un rythme assez
important c'était autant de question que
nous posions et autant de questions qu
aujourd'hui le monde occidental se pose
et la façon dont il observe aussi ce qui
se passe en egypte pour revenir à la
situation de séjour qui est une
situation forcément tendu je rejoins
tout à fait l'analyse de de ma collègue
à savoir que l'exercice est délicat dans
la mesure vous en imaginant que dans une
situation de chaos les islamistes prête
le pouvoir ce serait une rupture
aussitôt avec l'israël avec des risques
importants de déstabilisation de cette
zone du proche orient
c'est bien mon expertise dégâts le
premier ministre palestinien était reçu
ce matin il est en visite en france
pendant deux jours ils étaient ce matin
a reçu par le président du sénat gérard
larcher vous l'avez rencontrée vous
l'avez senti inquiet par la situation en
egypte
non on nous n'avons pas du tout parler
de l'egypte parce que ça va pas du tout
parce que salam fayyad lui a un objectif
politique auquel il se tient qui est
d'arriver à créer les instances d'un
état palestinien sans s'occuper du reste
et lui et son objectif c'est fin août
2011 non sur l'egypte je pense qu'il
faut revenir sur le fait qu' il n'y a
jamais eu d'état de droit
que ce soit sous nasser ou sous sadate
ou sous moubarak c'est pareil le l'état
de siège dure depuis le depuis la
présidence de saddam ça n'a jamais cessé
c'est immeuble yacoubian et vous verrez
ce que c'est que l'absence d'état de
droit il faut
cette année c'est un peuple d'une
patience infinie et pour réussir à le
jeter dans la rue il faut vraiment
l'avoir poussée au delà de toute
extrémité c'est il faut que la mise il
faut que la misère et surtout l'absence
de dignité lié à un pouvoir uniquement
répressif et pousser les égyptiens bout
encore faut-il qu'ils puissent y avoir
une alternative démocratique possible il
attendait une alternative démocratique
nous on n'a ni combien de temps en
france en faire une nous avons commencé
notre révolution en 1789 et nous avons
établi à grand-peine la troisième
république
en 1875 près d'un siècle je pense que
pour l'egypte il faudra pas mal tant il
y aura des salles et des venues au
risque de la déstabilisation d'une
région déjà très fragile
vous ne croyez pas que bonaparte a
sérieusement déstabiliser l'europe au
début du 20e siècle
nous nous sommes des peuples vieux du
design ou non du 19e nous sommes des
peuples vieux nous n'imaginons plus que
c'est que des peuples jeunes qui qui
veulent à tout prix sortir de delà de la
situation de dans laquelle on les a
placés les jeux et les égyptiens ont à
50% au moins 18 ans mais créer les
conditions du pluralisme de la diversité
politique qu'elle crée les conditions d
des libertés fondamentales comme la
liberté d'expression de la presse c'est
vrai c'est un exercice qui prend un peu
de temps faut passer bien sûr par
l'éducation je crois que c'est
extrêmement important nous c'était le
message qu'on souhaitait faire passer en
nous déplaçant là bas on avait prévu
toute une série de rencontres c'est
aussi les libéraux coup de tendre mais
dans un an je dirais dans une
alternative à ces courtes là dans un
premier temps qu'elle peut être
l'accompagnement par exemple de votre
groupe d'amitié bien c'est d'aller sur
place rencontrer
des intellectuels des membres de la
société civile en approche médias mais
dès que nous le pourrons nous nous irons
c'était bien notre intention nous avions
également prévu de rencontrer l'ensemble
des autorités religieuses seppi pour
faire passer aussi un message de
tolérance de respect mutuel et de paix
faire passer le message que comme en
france où nous avons le principe de
laïcité
chaque religion doit être respectée dans
dans son exercice
voilà c'est ce sont ces d un exercice
assez long mais qui doit absolument se
faire
la difficulté de rencontrer des gens
avec qui nous n'avons pas d'atomes
crochus et lors de la mission que nous
avions menée avec jean françois poncet
nous avions passé beaucoup de temps
rencontrer les islamistes et nous avons
pu constater qu'on s'a constaté à cette
occasion qu en egypte il était très
divisé et qu'en fait ceux qui étaient
les victimes de la répression étaient
les islamistes démocrate alors que les
autres étaient bien tranquille donc le
pouvoir laissé bien tranquille donc il y
a en fait il était très clair que les
islamistes ne veulent ils ont cédé gens
qui ont du temps devant eux et ils ne
veulent pas prendre le pouvoir politique
ça c'est une erreur de jugement de vue
d'europe de croire que les islamistes
veulent prendre le pouvoir politique ils
veulent garder une influence sur la
société et ils veulent avoir une
influence dans la politique mais pas le
prends pas prendre le pouvoir
bah écoute et on verra bien dans les
semaines qui arrivent ce qui va
réellement se passer en egypte merci à
tous les deux d'être venu sur le plateau
de public sénat pour refaire avec nous
la séance merci de nous avoir suivi sur
public sénat très bonne après midi à
tous sur notre antenne
cicek après leur arrivée en europe les
roms continuent à vivre de caravanes en
bidonvilles aux portes de nos sociétés
lui demander aux menus sont d'ailleurs
de mettre un terme aux implantations
sauvages de campements de roms ce sont
des gens de nous qu'on peut pas passer
en france
l'histoire des roms est jalonnée de
fantasmes on les roms subissent en effet
d'importants préjudices et on doit
changer les stéréotypes
ce qui pour nous représente le plus
grand progrès c'est que le nombre de
roms éduquer augmente chaque année
on voudrait montrer que les faits sont
roms ne concerne pas uniquement la
communauté des roms
elle concerne toute l'europe rome 1er
peuples européens vont